yeah if you follow me on Twitter you
knew this video was coming so let's go
ahead and talk about Fight Club and I
cleared it with Tyler Durden he says
it's cool I guess he likes my 80s hair
Fight Club right so Fight Club is
directed by David Fincher came out in
1999 actually it was considered a
box-office flop
yeah Fincher was in a bit of trouble
after Fight Club but luckily the people
band together and they made it a cult
phenomenon so now everyone loves Fight
Club
so Fight Club stars Edward Norton and
he's pretty much an average slub if ever
there was one did works in an office he
hates his job he's just miserable in
life he was like in a crowd you'd never
be able to pick him out he doesn't stand
out at all he's pretty much the staple
average person then he meets Tyler
Durden played by Brad Pitt and his life
completely changes the moment Brad Pitt
comes on-screen the moment you meet
Tyler Durden you're like that is one of
the coolest people ever put movies I
swear it the dude is just awesome he's
incredibly smart he just he says
everything that's perfect for the moment
you know I love characters like that
he's pretty much what every guy thinks
he is every guy honestly we all walk
around being like dude I'm totally like
Tyler Durden we're not but you know it's
cool to think if for nothing else Tyler
Durden is chaos I like characters like
that I like people like that he's just
so free in ways that people are not free
which is good for Edward Norton because
Edward Norton is one of those people who
needs to hold on to his structure you
know he's just like no this is this is
what I do this is my system either
Durin's like do just let go you are not
special you're not that beautiful and
unique snowflake embrace the reality of
your situation and you can do a lot more
and even change it it's that simple I
just agree with the dude is he extreme
yeah but he's supposed to be I don't
agree with everything he does but I'm
just saying there is an element of I a
dude is you know not wrong he always see
the hate comments about Fight Club
people like oh just [ __ ] up just about
guys fighting just violence solves
everything just fights and stupid
testosterone stupid
so yes the movies called Fight Club
because Edward Norton and Brad Pitt
start Fight Club but there's so much
more going on in the movie Fight Club
than just the Fight Club and calling
Fight Club Fight Club is like calling
the Empire Strikes Back the Battle of
Hoth yeah it's in it you know it's a
part of the movie but there is a lot
more going on
I mean you don't have to be a fighter to
connect with the movie Fight Club I
myself never been into a fight in my
life I guess no one's really wanted to
kick my ass like that and I love Fight
Club why because of the overarching
message of the movie and that is that
people are trapped in a box I mean these
people fighting this fight club as
Edward Norton says in the movie at the
end of the fight nothing is solved yet
nothing matters and is that kind of
freedom that people want to feel yet
they don't and that's why people can
connect with the movie Fight Club in the
end I love the character Tyler Durden
he's such a badass I love the way the
movie Fight Club just holds a mirror to
society it's just like that's what you
look like and it's ridiculous any movie
that slaps the PC society that we have
across the face it just lifts the common
man on its shoulders I am down with a
movie like that it's good stuff the
movie Fight Club is awesome tacular
every time I watch it I'm like this
movie has to be over three hours long it
just feels like a long movie but that's
because a lot of things happen in the
movie more than just you know fighting
like I said and I can say this if you
don't connect with the movie Fight Club
you should be commended because that
means you're just you've always been a
happy person and that's really the goal
it should be like that's a good job
however for the rest of you who have
felt really trapped in your life who
have worked 40 hours a week for a
company you hate or a boss that you
loathe for a wage that sucks ass you
will probably connect with the movie
Fight Club so what has been your
shittiest nine-to-five job that you've
had that you're just like no this is
miserable I hate it I need out comment
below let me know mine I was an
assistant manager at a sporting goods
store that's real I actually did that I
don't nothing about sports it was like
my own personal hell and I was miserable
funny Side Story also you know that like
moustache cop that I do on that's
actually my impersonation of the loss
prevention manager for that company he
was out of his mind and as always feel
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more